all right we're here to chat beauty
products it's one of my favorite things
I am a beauty junkie and I am so excited
to highlight the incredible skincare
line called loved one by the one and
only John Legend and joining me uh to
try these products is a super fan of
John I thought what better way to test
John's products than with a super fan
please welcome velita Spellman
thank you thank you for having me
you're a super fan of John's yes I don't
even think superfan is the word oh yes
yes may I ask what it is about him that
you know just so many things like his
voice oh my God is just oh it's like an
angel yeah yeah I know it really is he
just seems like such a good person yes
he is he really is and is it true that
you like
um had tickets to one of his concerts
actually well actually he was doing a
free concert and it was uh 2019.
and he was doing it at Union Station in
California and I had to leave town and
come back to New York so I was so
disappointed because who gets to see
John Legend for free and that was my
time honey sounds like a missed
connection yeah well if you don't mind
hopping up on this table of Lolita I am
going to test John's new Beauty line
um with you so if you just put your head
back there yeah we'll line you up
perfectly you tell me when you're
comfortable okay are you comfortable yes
I'm gonna put some cucumbers on your
eyes is that okay yes okay so keep them
closed there we go perfect oh you
already look Spa ready okay this is
perfect all right so we are going to
start with the cleanser I think that's
just a good place to start
um it's exfoliating
so how does it feel oh it feels nice oh
yeah refreshing
so when you missed John's concert what
would you have liked to have seen when
you know you were when you missed him
um I wanted to see I love his song um
Best You Ever Had I've heard that over a
thousand times
is the night
[Applause]
oh my God
oh my God uh how are you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh my god well wow did you enjoy your
facial oh my goodness okay felita meet
John John
[Applause]
my pleasure my pleasure
now obviously we're gonna send you home
with all of John's worse
you can get your loved one on
um but before we go to commercial break
if there is anything you ever wanted to
say to John
an opportunity
the best you ever had for me please face
this what you came from
don't you wish you came on
God's plan for oh come on come on let me
kiss that oh I know you missed that
what's wrong let me fix that twist that
baby tonight good night I let you know
baby tonight the night we lose control
baby tonight you need that tonight
believe that tonight I'll be the best
you ever had
hey
everybody
oh my goodness
[Applause]
[Music]